this and more with senate minority
leader mitch mcconnell
senator welcome back to special report
hey brett
i want to start with the covid relief
bill
this was president biden this afternoon
about
about that bill take a listen
critics say the plan is too big that it
costs too much
but let me ask a rhetorical question
what would you have me
cut what would you have me cut out
what would you have him cut senator
that's a good question first of all the
minimum wage doesn't belong in there the
congressional budget office says it
would cost
1.4 million jobs we'd
lose second 350 billion dollars for
bailouts to poorly run states
clearly not necessary with regard to the
school funding that they
added by the way the school funding that
we've already provided is not yet spent
out
in a bill we passed just a couple of
months ago
but of the school funding that they add
only five percent of it is used this
year
the rest of it spent out in future years
i thought this was
supposed to be a package about covet
relief
this is wildly more expensive brett
than the country needs at this
particular time because the vaccines are
rolling out
shots are getting into arms the economy
is
getting better and better i think
my 10 moderate republicans went down to
see the president suggested
that they could justify about five or
six hundred
billion dollars this is two trillion to
put that in context that's what we spent
at the height
of the pandemic last april it's
wildly too expensive and full of
democratic
ass that they want to take advantage of
under the name of covet relief
so do you expect to lose any republicans
on this bill
well certainly hope not we didn't lose
any on the
first round which was the budget which
makes possible
the second round the budget
reconciliation that we expect
to get over from the house soon
do you think that democrats are
positioning uh possibly
not only with covid this covet bill but
other bills
to try to use reconciliation the process
by which they only need
50 plus one yeah they they are
and they will probably try to do one
more
and in it you can anticipate all of your
taxes going up
business taxes going up which of course
will be bad for the economy
individual taxes going up now these guys
live to raise taxes and no matter what
they call the next package
you can anticipate it'll have a very
significant tax increase for the
american people
senator back under president bush 43
you were a proponent of ear marks so
right now
should congress reinstate earmarks
restore that spending authority
essentially went to the executive branch
yeah i think earmarks are very unpopular
among republicans i think we're very
unenthusiastic there may be some
republicans
interested in that's sort of
what's called congressionally directed
spending it doesn't enjoy much
support among republicans either in the
house or the senate
so you've switched your thinking about
it obviously you were a proponent before
well i represent the entire conference
and i can tell you the overwhelming
majority of the
republican conference in the senate is
not in favorable even if the democrats
craft the bill so that those are
permitted
will not be asking for them i want to
talk about nominees
specifically nira tandon why do you want
to hold the gop
line on the omb director nominee near
attendant
well she's excessively partisan
[Music]
she tweeted frequently we're
accustomed to that these days but she
took
shots at everybody she's taken
offensive shots at almost all of my
members
you think of people in charge of omb
as being kind of honest brokers that you
can talk to and she's been
so partisan that she's generated
opposition from even my most
moderate members for example like
senator collins
senator romney who are always looking
for opportunities to be cooperative with
the administration
this is just another example of the fact
that the president has chosen
a very progressive beginning his chief
of staff on msnbc yesterday
said with regard to the covet package
the most progressive
legislation in a generation the
president has decided not to be a
centrist
and therefore he shouldn't expect much
republican support for these kind of
initiatives
you know democrats point to trump
nominees like rick grinnell who is a
prolific
partisan tweeter who did not have any
problem getting through a confirmation
vote but more importantly
critics of this hold up say
you know republicans didn't even address
some of president trump's tweets
that dealt specifically with people yeah
i think a lot of my members chose not to
comment on the president's daily
tweeting
i was among them and we concluded that
was not a constructive use of our time
so you don't think there's a difference
there as far as
holding one side accountable or not
well i think when it comes to being
confirmed
your record is before the senate the
senate's in the personnel business
unlike the house and so when members
come up for confirmation their whole
record
is before us and in this day and age
tweeting is part of your record
all right we're just 12 days senator
since you're really blistering speech on
the senate floor
about former president trump here's just
a piece of that
he did not do his job
he didn't take steps so federal law
could be
faithfully executed and order restored
no instead
according to public reports he watched
television happily
happily as the chaos unfolded
sorry i interrupted you there with your
your speech uh
you were saying well look my point is
what happened in the past is not
something relevant now we're moving
forward
we've got a new administration it's a
very left-wing administration we need to
make sure the american people understand
that this is not what republicans stand
for
i want to say this about the president
having chosen the progressive
route he certainly made it a lot easier
for me to unify
my members in opposition
you're talking about president biden but
the reason it's relevant and obviously
i'm sure you read the lengthy statement
from
the former president saying the
republican party can never again be
respected or strong with political
leaders like senator mitch mcconnell at
its helm
mcconnell's dedication to business as
usual status quo policies together with
his
lack of political insight wisdom skill
and personality has rapidly driven him
from majority leader to minority leader
it goes on very specifically when you
read that what was your reaction
the republican party is actually in very
good shape
we gained seats in the house we
elected 50 republican senators when
everybody was predicting we were going
to lose the senate
the democrats didn't flip a single state
legislature
we flipped two picked up a governor the
republican party had a very good day on
november 3rd
we're sorry we lost the white house but
the republican party
demonstrated once again this is a 50-50
nation
we're very competitive and we'll be
competitive again
in 22. do you blame the former president
for losing the two georgia
senate seats i don't have any further
observations to make
about that we're looking forward okay
dealing with the new administration
and trying to hold the senate in 22. let
me you know it's ahead of this big
speech this weekend at cpac
should the former president be speaking
at cpac this weekend
i don't have any advice to give the
former president about where he should
speak or what he should say
okay is there a civil war in the gop
currently
no i think if you're looking for a real
civil war look at the democrats in the
house
the progressives making it extremely
difficult
for speaker pelosi to operate give them
a narrow
margin she has overall in the house
i think the biden administration is
making it easy for us to get together
and
i think we've unified in opposition to
this new administration's extremely
progressive
approach president biden has made it
quite easy for us to get together
the there'll be a lot of talk this
weekend about 2024 and whether the
former president is going to get in that
mix here's what senator romney
said about that if he does
will president trump continue to play a
role in my party i'm sure he will
he has by far the largest voice and a
big impact in my party
i don't know about his family members
whether they intend to do that
but but i expect he will continue
playing a role i don't know if he'll run
in 2024 or not but if he does
i yeah i'm pretty sure he will win the
nomination
you agree with that well there's a lot
to happen between now and 24 i've got at
least four members that i think are
planning on running for president plus
some for
some governors and others there's no
incumbent
should be a wide open race and fun for
you all to cover
if the president was the party's nominee
would you support him
uh the nominee of the party absolutely
i want to ask you a couple more things
the 911 style commission that speaker
pelosi is talking about for january 6th
obviously what you said on the floor was
very specific you voted to acquit
but there's an investigation into what
happened that day on all elements of
security
are you for or against that
far against investigating well some of
our committees have been having hearings
on that very subject
this week i'm open to a 9 11
type commission but it's got to be even
like the 9 11 commission was if we're
going to
do an outside commission review of the
events of january 6. it needs to be
structured
similar to the 911 commission and you
might have noticed that the chairs of
the 911 commission have already
come out against nancy pelosi's approach
to this because it's not balanced
that one was balanced both lee hamilton
and tom kane who chaired that outside
commission
back after 9 11 even refused to go on
sunday shows
except together it was a totally
bipartisan effort that's what's needed
in order to have
credibility attached to the final report
that kind of commission i'm open to
nothing
close to what the speaker's uh proposing
i'm
open to senator i only have 30 seconds
left but what would you say the trump
supporters
who read the president's statement about
you
and are concerned about the future of
the gop
what i would say to everybody who's
inclined to support
our right of center republican party
let's focus on winning
the house and the senate in 22
that will set up the next nominee for
president whoever that may be
the best chance to be victorious
senator i always have more questions for
you wish i had more time but we
appreciate your time on special report
thanks a lot